ynet
allez debout
véritable phénomène mondial la vague du
stand de paddle des ferries maintenant à
la réunion l'australien scott mckay
rusher windsurfers en retraite et actuel
développeurs des planches pour une
grande marque de paddle board nous
explique les raisons de cet engouement
pour ce sport ancestral venu d'hawaï
c'était à l'occasion de son séjour à la
réunion
il y à une rapide progression entre ce
qu'on considérait avant comme des
longboards c'est à dire des planches de
trois mètres femmes est de 60 en très
peu de temps elles sont devenues plus
court de plus en plus large et que ceux
qui parlent équilibre plus facile sur
l'eau
tout le monde peut en faire de 5 à 77
euros
ces dernières années le niveau de
performance en paddle a vraiment atteint
des sommets
par rapport aux faits justement que les
planches soit plus courte plus rapide et
plus maniable
ceux qui avant était considérée comme
une petite planche est aujourd'hui une
longboard tout devient plus petit à
mesure que les riders deviennent plus
performants
ça va être intéressant de voir jusqu'où
ça va aller dans les années à venir
là
globalement il y à beaucoup d'endroits
au monde où on peut partager les vagues
avec les surfeurs il suffit de ne pas
être trop gourmand car il faut
reconnaître qu'en paddle on remonte les
vagues beaucoup plus facilement donc
avec du respect tu gagnes le respect et
tout se passe bien
s'il ya beaucoup de surfeurs à l'eau
alors on va aller chercher une vague
plus éloignée plus difficilement
accessible aux surfeurs
c'est une question de mentalité s'il y a
bon surfeur à l'eau il va pouvoir lui
aussi prendre plus de vagues qu'un
surfeur moins expérimentés ce n'est donc
pas une question de type de planche
c'est vraiment une affaire de mentalité
si chacun attend son tour chacun peut
prendre une vague ce n'est pas une
histoire d'avoir une pagaie dans les
mains c'est vraiment une histoire
mentalité pour moi
on
là
il